[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh great guest today
Ryan good to see you uh you okay there
the uh I think you're gonna have to hold
your microphones no it's it's a little
gravity's not on my side but Hi how are
you cause you got love love loving your
side hey guys I hope you have a I had a
great weekend I was in uh Vegas
um it was amazing I was at the creation
con the supernatural con with Jensen and
Jared we took pictures together it was
so fun my buddy's band loud and swing
all my buddies playing that band uh
Billy Moran plays on all three albums
that I've done of mine
it was just a great time the fans are
unbelievable
um love chatting with them I thought
they weren't going to like us because we
weren't Supernatural but they're sort of
a crossover because they aired after we
did on Tuesday nights I believe and also
Jensen was on Smallville for I think
like a season or two and uh we worked
together so we I took like 50 pictures
of the gents and it was really funny
um but it was it was great Vegas was fun
I was locked out of my Twitter account
so hopefully yeah yeah so I don't know
what's going on there
um I don't know how to get back in I
don't I don't know I think that was
hacked I think
I I don't know I do not know what
happened they said you need to be a
two-factor verification and I go okay
I'll do that and I did that and after
that just locked I don't know what
happened I don't know something happened
maybe it wasn't for hacked oh I don't I
don't know but um uh Twitter help me
although Twitter kind of sucks anyway
you know
Instagram's like the thing well now
you're definitely not gonna get it
well I mean look look how they're
treating me I'll say something nice if
they fix it but right now I'm pissed I'm
fine
um Tom Welling and I will be listening
to this Dallas Texas with creation with
Jensen and Jared and the Gang uh
February 4th and fifth we're doing a
Smallville nights on February 4th get
your tickets now it was awesome you're
gonna you're gonna love it we do have an
hour and a half show there's prizes
there's we read scripts it's it's a real
blast
um and also please uh go to Spotify or
apple or ever get you get your music and
our my new album's out sunspin the band
is Sun spin you could get it for free
everywhere or you can go to iTunes and
and get the songs You could also go to
shop uh oh sorry sunspin.com
and you could buy merch and CDs
keepsakes whatnot t-shirts support us
and uh really appreciate that and also
the inside of you online store if you
want awesome inside of you merchandise
and autograph Lexus scripts and uh
there's like ship Keys autographed and
scr there's just tons of cool [__] Ryan
nice but anyway and of course last but
not least and I'll get into it patreon
patreon.com inside of you for folks who
want to support the podcast you know
without you I can't do this podcast
period without the patrons supporting
the podcast and giving back a little it
just would be impossible so thank you
all my level of patrons I I send you
boxes every couple of months and
hopefully new people will listen and
join patreon patreon.com inside you a
great guest today you know I knew this
guy Ryan
from he did this like it was like a sort
of a Star Wars movie it wasn't a Star
Wars movie but it was about going to
break in Lucas Ranch it was like back in
the it was it was a Fanboys Fanboys yeah
yeah so my friend uh file
Newman he directed it and this guy was
in it Dan fogler who's really funny yeah
and Dan Fogle was kind of a guy that's
known for his comedy like you watch him
you're like oh this guy's he's the funny
guy you know great at what he does yeah
and I stumbled upon this new show in the
last six months on Paramount plus I
believe it's called the offer it's the
making of The Godfather told in in a way
with actors about how it was made yeah
so it's uh I I had to have him on the
podcast I I won't tell him how I got his
email but I got it from a friend
from a friend's friend and I just said
dude you were unbelievable in the show
we kind of know each other through some
people
would you do the podcast
and he finally did it
and uh he was he played Francis Ford
Coppola and I'm telling you he was
genius this if you haven't seen this
show the offer you're in for a treat uh
it's just how hard it was to make movies
how hard it is to make movies but this
one in particular was uh pretty crazy uh
anyway I love this guy he really opened
up about his life about what he wants
what he's doing
um and about the Godfather and how hard
it was to to make this uh to make that
movie and without further Ado let's just
do it let's get inside of Dan fogler
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how you doing
I'm good
I'm glad you did this man I'm glad you
did this you know it's I don't think
have we met because I think we have a
lot of the same friends and I've always
heard your name come up you've always
taken roles from me but I've never
actually met
the Dan fogler
is that true well
uh it feels like we know each other
forever it does I already feel
warm I feel warm you feel warm inside
does it
I do I feel like I know you so I'm just
gonna pretend like I do
cheers cheers to you my friend is that a
mimosa
I'll say yeah no it's uh it's sparkling
water with orange juice
I need a little uh Citrus in there you
know in a wine glass
very fancy yeah that was all that was
left in the in the cupboard are you are
you a fancy guy I don't I don't take you
as fancy I don't think you like going to
fancy restaurants I mean I like to uh
but I'm not like
constantly like oh I gotta go to that
fancy restaurant
but I enjoy them I enjoy the Finer
Things but I'm pretty low maintenance
I'm used I'm normally the guy who like
has a few places that I order from and I
just keep going to those places I don't
like to get out of the house much I have
there's a couple of places if I do go
out I'll go to I'm just I gotta get out
of my box man I gotta get out of it yeah
your creature a habit yeah me too man
I'm I'm the same way um I have my
favorites in my go-to's and and I'm open
to hear other people's suggestions
but uh I usually go to my same old same
old you know it's just easy you're just
like they delivered
they're loyal it was good
exactly that's right yeah that's that's
that's good
um do you uh do you have a lot of
friends that you hang out with or is it
mostly just you the wifey and the kids
um in London here
yeah we have
well yeah we have
um her family's out here so we see them
quite a bit I have a couple friends that
um
are live here but I
I have friends that come in like
vacation and and like coming for like a
week or whatever and pop in and
so that's cool
um yeah where are you at man I'm in La
I'm in LA are you filming something
right now
I'm living here I'm about to film
something uh in Rome
so it's it's more convenient to be here
um but uh yeah no I'm living here man
it's it's crazy yeah I've been living
here since the lockdown
because
um I was shooting the third Fantastic
Beasts movie yeah and I had the family
out here and we got a nice situation out
here that Joe that my wife inherited
from her family so it's a nice house and
and so I was literally like
all mustached up ready to like go to go
to my first shoot day
and they were like they turned the car
around I was like what's going on we're
like uh well there you know we're we're
gonna shut down for a little bit and
then and then it was like months
so I was supposed to be there for six
months and it turned into a year and a
half so during that time
my wife and I were just like all right
the kids are in school here and we
didn't know what the hell was happening
in America we were just like let's let's
figure out how to become residents here
just in case
and you know I don't know if you got
kids but it's all about the kids like
their comfortability
they're in school they like it so it's
just like all right we'll we'll this
checks just takes off uh just ticks off
a lot of boxes for us
I never thought I'd be living here but
here we are do they do they like
Fantastic Beasts it's a big production
big Studio movies did they during the
covid since they have you sort of on
hold they have to keep paying you more
and more as part of a policy or do they
just say no you're getting paid the same
but you're just sort of on hold until
we're ready
yeah I know it's like um they shut down
production so that means that they they
shut everything down so you don't get
paid at all
I didn't say it
that sounds like a real drag you know
you say you lived in La you live in
London I don't know I and you have a lot
of English I don't have a lot of English
friends
um
I I think that English people for the
most part make me nervous
um I do have English but it's just the
way they speak and I just feel like oh
my God I'm stupid I don't know what it
is but it's just like yeah so we're
going to meet at this restaurant I'm
like oh my God I'm nervous already oh
this sounds like this I'd have to wear I
have to dress up but I have to talk a
certain way you don't feel that do you
no for me it's like I feel like they're
they just are
part of the Empire because I I grew up
on Star Wars so I just uh
that's part of the dark side no uh yeah
I was um when I first when I was
shooting the first movie
and I got here
and
yeah I felt like I felt like Britain was
uh
I just had it in my head like they're
they are superior and yeah and it was
yeah and so like I like I wouldn't open
my mouth I would just be like I would
point at things I'd be like
I want that you know I was like ashamed
of my and then when I started talking I
you know it was like uh I would just try
to I would like put on an accent
I would do like a Jason straight from
Connor so it kind of sounded like Nick
uh Frost
who's been on the podcast I love him
yeah yeah yeah that's good yeah I would
do it like a fake accent and that would
I was able to get by like that for a
while I just want a ham sandwich
it's so stupid and you'd stay in it
you'd stay in that character I'd stay in
it you know those first couple months
um it was cool you know you
you test out accents yeah but people
like
people would hear like wait that's not
quite right you know something's wrong
where is he from what area is he from
hmm right and then they start asking you
questions you're just like all right
mate gotta go
getting nervous uh dude I'm looking at
your your career and everything and I've
seen some interviews with you I mean
you've done so many different things
it's like you know obviously uh Good
Luck Chuck and Fanboys and Fantastic
Beasts franchise take me home tonight
which I was just talking about uh
Walking Dead
and what really blew me away was because
I've seen you know these things I'm like
oh he's so funny he's always good he
always brings it but I I emailed you or
I messaged you because I saw you in the
offer and it just blew me away
it blew me away I was like this because
I don't you don't get to be serious as
much as you get to be kind of funny guy
right
yeah yeah but boy I mean they gave me a
chance well they always say
uh comedy's harder right as an actor so
the comedy's harder serious is easier I
I always felt like that too do you feel
like that
yeah absolutely because yeah you don't
have to
comedy is like math you have to you have
to hit it's like music if you don't hit
the right chords if you don't hit the
right
oh and they're not gonna laugh and it's
just like it doesn't work you know so
it's it's a real art but drama
you can just be yeah you know don't make
anyone laugh you just you just are
um and that could be funny too you can
find some dark hysterical moments in
there but
uh it's a lot easier and I like
like I went to college
um for acting and so I did all sorts of
dramatic stuff check off and yep you
know with Uncle Vanya and [__]
Shakespeare and Mammoth so like I I knew
I had all that stuff in my pocket from
when I was in my 20s
and so everyone you know everyone's got
their own course of how to get
uh it's where they're at in in um I've
had a couple of moments where I was able
to do some drama along the way
like I get to be more
um
like even even if I'm in
like The Walking Dead for example I'm
still more of a jovial character right
uh but I do I do get to do just a lot of
dark dark moments yeah
um Coppola man he's he's a serious dude
and Jesus so that was like and he's he's
obviously an iconic legend alive
um it was a lot it was big shoes to step
into and um
and he and he can be kind of funny you
know and in some ways so you met him no
but I feel like um
I've seen him
you know he's eccentric uh and he's
passionate
and
you know he like
there are moments in Apocalypse Now that
are
surreal hysterical
um uh heart and like heart to Darkness
you watch him in that but he's in
Apocalypse Now and that moment is so
surreal and hysterical where he just saw
don't look at me keep going
yeah yeah I remember that she could just
like you know it takes it takes a a
Darkly comedic mind to no he he that's
an opera like The Godfather is an opera
he creates like Dracula's are these like
operas and so
you have to hit every note on the piano
you have to hit every
uh color on the palette like that's what
he does so there is this there's a
little comedy and everything and
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection you guys if you
haven't seen the offer it's the
Paramount plus Paramount Plus
the offer I I don't tell you to watch a
lot of things this is a great series if
you've never heard of it it's sort of
like how the Godfather movie came to be
how it was made and all the difficulties
the adversity they faced which I had no
idea the [__] that this movie almost
went down went under so many times and
the stories are so fascinating that
you're like this can't be true and then
you start looking [__] up after you're
watching you're like wow this is true
this happened
yeah yeah life is even Stranger in
fiction
um
yeah and the show
had did kind of um
squeeze in a couple a couple years of
history there
um but there was there's
I'd say about you know 85 percent of
that show is are real things that
happened and real
um like every day was a battle just to
make
the movie yeah uh like like first
um like Coppola first Coppola didn't
want to make it he was just like I don't
know I don't like how it makes
Italians look and and then like the
legend is is that
uh George Lucas was just like dude
they're gonna they're gonna shut this
place down they're gonna they're gonna
lock the doors of American Zoe Trope you
gotta do this movie so it's just like he
was like okay and
and then um in meeting Mario Puzo
he just
um
found this kindred spirit who was just
like
this
you know other because
um he's basically a writing genius
copelism it was a writing genius in his
own right he wrote Pat and won the
Academy Award for that and so he really
hit it off with with Mario and and
um and from them they really paired down
the gold from that novel
uh and those are some of my favorite
scenes oh yeah when you're with Puzo and
Puzo and just sitting there and have a
sandwich with a sandwich thing and the
yeah it's just it's it's hilarious and
you're like how are they gonna do this
how are we gonna get anything done
see it's funny there's there's funny
moments it's like
yeah they're uh the two of them
the two of them are a great Odd Couple
in a lot of ways yeah
kuzo is just like it's you know sloppy
and couples just like stay on stay on
target yeah the other genius I think
everybody's performance in that movie
was in that show in the series was
fantastic it's the offer brilliant I'm
not just saying this it's it's a
brilliant show I couldn't stop watching
I could not go to sleep I had to watch
it and the guy who plays Robert Evans
what's his name Matthew good is like a
time machine I call him the time machine
he's Robert Evans he's [__] Robert
Evans I saw the Robert Evans documentary
the kid stays in the picture I've heard
him talk I've heard he is Robert Evans
it's unbelievable how he nailed that
and he's a British guy it's crazy oh my
God
I was yeah I call him the time machine
because
out of like I love working with
everybody
miles Juno like like Burn Gorman like
there everybody was so fun to work with
um but Matthew was Bob Evans and there
were moments where
I would be sitting there and I'd have
like from my point of view I have the
Coppola glasses on you know
and I'm looking down at Coppola's
thoughts in his gigantic you know
notebook that he had
that broke down every inch of the The
Godfather script
so I literally would just be like
holding authentic thoughts of Coplay in
my hand and then in my periphery there
would be Matthew just as Bob
and I would feel the paramounts the
Paramount logo like on the wall and I
would have out of body experiences I
would like
I would have these moments where I was
like oh my God what's my what's my line
I would just be like whoa am I am I here
right now look wow I felt like I was I
felt like I was in the office with Bob
Evans and it was just that's insane
it was it was it wasn't like I jumped
into Coppola's body or something like
that I would it was very surreal and it
happened a lot with Matthew as wild did
you ever do your Al Pacino on set
oh yeah Anthony Polito who played Pacino
who did a great job yeah it was great
and he was just kind of playing young
young Al Pacino and the which I thought
he like nailed it and everybody was I I
do more on all the you know Albert you
know like whatever like everyone had a
had a pachito instead and so it was it
was crazy it was like dueling pacinos
anytime Anthony was on set and he was a
good sport uh thank God you know but
yeah that's fun man come on that's just
brilliant did you get the offer or did
you have to no pun intended but did you
have to or did you have to audition
repeatedly they wanted to see what you
could do was it a tough get I auditioned
I made a tape so
what happened was
my my reps emailed me and they were like
we want you to they they want you to
audition for for Coppola and I was like
okay great
and then I got the email with the sides
and the header said Coppola but it was
Puzo sides
and I was like Oh I thought it was for
Coppola and they were like no they want
you to audition for Puzo and I was like
can I also audition for Coppola and they
were like okay so so right away like if
I hadn't said that who knows what would
have happened wow so I so I sent in an
audition for Copeland for Puzo so
um first I did Coppola
and I put my hair to the side
and I had the beard and I put the
glasses on
and I was like holy [__] I look like him
you know I was like I didn't like really
put that together but then I was like
okay this is this is not so hard to look
like him and then
um
and then I when I do my auditions on
tape I I also
but I taped the lines of the of the
reader so and I play them back so I'm
basically reading one myself
and um
so I was reading I was I was Pacino we
did the scene where
um Coppola and Pacino are in are in uh
the restaurant bathroom and he's talking
about getting the gun behind the you
know behind the the pull uh chain for
the tank you know in the bathroom there
and that famous scene and so I'm
auditioning
with that scene as Coppola
but also playing Pacino off camera so I
was like okay that's that's pretty
awesome like not that I would ever play
Pacino but I was like they you know and
then I shaved
and I put my hair you know back and I
put other different glasses on and then
I was I did Puzo and I did the scene
where Puzo goes into Jason's
and he meets Frank Sinatra that crazy
[__] scene where he ends up insulting
each other and they're like he like goes
to stab him with a fork yeah so I read
so I read Puzo and then I also I also
read Frank Sinatra
and I sent all that in I was just like
whether I get this or not
I just read for four different roles you
know for this freaking thing and I sent
it in and then I got I got I got Coppola
how did you how did you uh
I mean did you memorize oh you memorize
all your lines are you a good auditioner
I I uh I go to I've for auditions
because they just happen quickly like
that and you got to be off book
um I got a couple different methods I
have the lines in my ears sometimes
um how do you do that how do you do the
lines in your ear
you oh you you take like you have your
your thing like this or you preferably
uh
one that's like uh black or something
right Blends in and you put it over your
ear like that you stick it in there and
you flip it behind there and you just
it's you just get everything I just
record all my lines and I can just hear
my line in my ear and just say it and
just and but but that's hard because you
usually have to have a reader
so you have to wait for their timing
it's a it's a whole mind [__] so I
stopped doing that
um and
uh nowadays I just do the Brando thing
and I just have my sides taped off
camera so you never really memorize your
lines
no you gotta pay me for that man dude I
holy [__] man I'm gonna start doing that
yeah I'm not kidding because that's how
I feel I'm like I don't want to learn
six pages of dialogue to say not
possible I don't have the time
who has the time who has a 40 we used to
have the time Dan no I never had I was
terrible at it that's why I became a
good improviser because I always
go up on my line and I gotta fill in the
gaps and that's that's you know
sometimes that makes it into the movie
and sometimes it doesn't
depending on if the director writer
whatever like like um can you get my
line exactly correctly with all the
punctuation you know you never know who
you're going to be dealing with there
but do you usually know your lines when
you're on set most for the most part
yeah I try to be very off book but I
know just just I'm human that at some
point I'm gonna mess up my lines and I
don't like to mess up my lines I don't
like to to stop the whole production I
like because I'm from theater right I
like to keep the ball in the air so if I
[__] up my line I will continue with
something else staying camera character
until someone else feeds him my line or
I remember or whatever but I don't ever
stop the scene I just keep on going
until they say cut are you um when you
look back when you started in theater
and all that stuff when you're sitting
here at your age what are you 46 45 44
what is it yeah keep going down 44. I'm
40. uh sold sold to the man of the beard
uh
are you this is a weird question are you
where you thought you'd be are you a lot
further along than you thought you'd be
or are you expecting to be way bigger of
an actor what was in your mind what kind
of ego what kind of if you look back
I think I got exactly what I wanted like
I always wanted well I'm you know I'm I
got a lot
what's crazy is
that I was in college they were like
you're not gonna work until you're 38.
because you're a character actor and I
was like holy [__] I was like
um and and basically they were they were
right like I didn't really like
fit into my body and like really own my
my character until around that time but
I was like [__] you I want to work
earlier than that I would hope yeah I
gotta make some money there so it put a
fire in my uh in my belly to just like
prove them wrong
and I did I started working in
like by like 28 you know which was
10 years earlier than they predicted and
then um
but I've had certain lulls
in my career where I was like that
didn't go well that didn't go as planned
and I've had to you know life happens
and then I've had to
I've had a couple Miracles like I've had
to wish on Stars
for opportunities that have happened
like Fantastic Beasts
um that came out of the blue
which I was like whoa like I in my head
I was just like where the [__] did this
audition come from
I thought that I would have to
get this roll down here and prove myself
in this next role here in order to be
even anywhere near contention to be in
that room for that audition but for some
reason I was suddenly in that room maybe
because
they were looking for a certain type or
whatever but they [__] looked at
everybody they I auditioned
and then they were like okay great
and then they'd audition everybody uh uh
from here to the moon and then they come
back to me a couple months later so it
was just like
I've had these moments that were
Miracles happened where
like I was on Broadway for the first
time in in spelling bee this was my big
break
I got a [__] Tony Award the first
time I'm on Broadway if I didn't think
that was gonna happen that was a miracle
to me I was like okay Miracles are
possible you are you do get these
moments where
the universe conspires in your favor and
just gives you a leg up because
when I won the Tony award that's when
movie offers started happening
so you get these opportunities
um
and
the offer was kind of the same thing
like the offer
like I I thought that okay I've been
doing good work and
and Fantastic Beasts I'm I'm doing some
serious stuff but but
I I would think that I would have to
play in my thinking is like okay I would
have to play
balushi I would have to play Sam Kinison
I would have to play something like that
first
do well in order to improve myself in
order to be even be in contention to
audition for Coppola
you see I I understand exactly but but
you know I I feel like the same person I
I never thought they would consider me
really for Lex Luthor I never in a
million years my friends would all say
dude you're a [__] idiot how are you
playing a mastermind I I don't know like
dude I mean come on you're like you're a
wiener you're not gonna and like I
couldn't see it and if a lot of times
you hear this by these coaches you know
they're like if you can't see it nobody
else can see it it's a mind game it is
you gotta believe it and then it can and
then you can
will it to happen but even when it
happens you're saying you're like how
the [__] did this happen
yeah I mean well well yeah because
there is a kind of moment there where
especially with something like Coppola
where it's just like
okay I gotta
prove to a lot of people that I can do
this I can prove it to myself I gotta do
it
so
first couple days on set or a little
you know uh stressful but
you do scenes
and
you read the the room you know and
Dexter Fletcher who was the director was
like a [__] hypnotist like he was
just like this incredible
a cheerleader where like from
the moment like I was in costume and he
was like you're here
you're doing it man yeah you are coping
you're just him you know just be like
okay I'm him I I you're right you know
and he was just like I had this amazing
talent to just instill confidence
so very early on and then I was like I
trusted it I was like okay I don't got
to see playback I'm just gonna keep
doing what I'm doing and
because when I think when you're dealing
with something so
so much importance in in our business
you know like that some someone like
Coppola
I think you have to just like Let It Go
and just play and or you'll kill
yourself I mean you're like beat
yourself down
and also like having someone like this
director imagine if you had some
director who was just like an [__] or
wasn't really present they're like oh
let's do another one let's do it again
all right great that's moving on that
you didn't trust then you're gonna spend
the whole feature going I'm going to be
laughing do I suck what's going on you
need we need as actors we need some
Assurance we need some uh some trust to
know that we're on the right path we're
doing the right thing if we don't get
that and we just very few have the
confidence to just trust herself and no
one else you need someone else to kind
of guide you a little bit don't you
yeah you need to you need to that's why
you want you you want an actor's
director
Dexter it's been acting since he's a kid
like if you're in a comedy or something
and and the director's a little wonky or
they're like a new director
you can at least say hey can I see some
playback you know can I see the dailies
they're more they're more open to that
so so you can at least gauge your
performance you know
um and in the Moment Like especially
it's it's but but with like a drama
there's not a lot of looking at playback
you know there's not a lot of hovering
around you know the yeah
no time really right oh well there
there's time but it's
it's not
it's a different kind of animal it's
like
because
the in comedies it's like you're look
you're
it's it's you get this little audience
and you're standing around the you know
the director's tent and see what's funny
let's see what's working you can see
like you're watching the playback and
it's like it's a group effort you're
like yeah yeah that worked okay let's go
back and do another but it's
okay
I don't know if it's the same but it's
like it's almost too pretentious if it's
drama yeah it's like you can't really
have that audience to go oh yeah that
was really good it's just different like
I remember I did this movie and it was
Steve Martin and Steve would go to the
to the playback ever monitors every take
every take and he go well I can go
bigger there I can go bigger and I was
like oh wow look I was learning from him
oh yeah
I was not it was called Bringing Down
the House I wore a horrible wig and I
just wanted to work with Steve Martin
and he was lovely but um
he's the best I mean the first day comes
on set and goes tell me about this
Smallville
and uh we hit it off and I'd be at lunch
and go do you mind if I sit here with
you and I go yeah Steve sit down we've
hung out in this trailer he played the
the engine the banjo he signed my jerk
poster which is somewhere in this house
um he was awesome man he was he was
Delight um that's good you talked about
LOLs like you know you had those lulls
you're like oh what's happening this
didn't work I didn't do well do you do
you get anxiety do you get depression do
you have things that you do for it uh do
you go to therapy what is it that you
how do you deal with things how do you
deal with life rejection yeah it helps
it helps to create a philosophy for
yourself where it's just like do or die
where you're just like
okay whether
like when I set out to be an actor I was
like I don't care if I make a penny at
this
I'm gonna be doing this till I'm 99
years old on the side of a road with a
hat just being like hello my baby you
know it's like doing like oh like tap
dancing for people and like you know I
really really that's true like if you
were making no money you wouldn't have
quit eventually you would have get you
wouldn't have given up you would have
kept doing uh a Repertory Theater
whatever it was
till I died
I would have just kept acting
yeah because
um
I don't know man I just like
it was it's my jam like it's like like
if I like I don't know like if I
couldn't Act
I would be doing some other
right brain thing
you know like that doesn't make money
like sculpting on the side of the road
you are a sculptor you're a Sculptor
yeah but like you know if it's you know
it's a hobby but um wait if I offered
you 50 million dollars cash 50 million
and I said you can never act again
oh
[__] it's kind of sad here's 50 million
you can never act again no never act
again
holy crap
I'd have to talk to my wife for for that
we can act in front of each other nope
can't even act in front of each other
you can't even pretend to like things
wow 50 million it's a lot of money I
don't know man
feel like I would still like sneak away
and make like indie films like secret
films to feed the beast in my belly God
yeah that's amazing oh that's amazing
that you even ponder that because if
somebody said I'll give you five I'd be
like [__] yeah five million let's I'm
done let's move on to uh I'll direct
I'll do whatever I'll travel
I don't know I still got something to
prove like like if I had done like
if I had gotten to this point and you
offered me the same thing and I'd be
like oh yeah I've done all my favorite
roles and all the things I wanted to do
and you know then I would say like yeah
I guess I could step away from
from acting and that would be a kind of
like a rock and roll kind of thing and
just live you know uh but I haven't I
haven't but you just said I I have to I
still have to prove do you have to prove
to yourself or do you have to prove to
everyone else be honest because a lot of
it's like I want to show you that I'm a
[__] brilliant actor or is do you
want to just prove to yourself too that
you're capable of doing that
I know I'm capable of doing it I I know
I know like because like I said like in
in college like
I did the full spectrum
of like I I had like a a really good
idea of what my abilities were in
college
as
what I would call
um a sad clown the kind of actor that
can make you cry in one sentence and
make you sad and make you happy in the
next sentence
um and
that's what I always wanted to be
watching
uh actors like Robin Williams who I love
and uh may he rest in peace and like I
was like not that I'm anywhere near the
quickness of Robin or his talent but I
was I would strive to be like him
and
um I knew in college that I like I was
like oh I can make people laugh and I
can make people cry
and
I've been given chances to do that in
certain roles over the years but I
haven't there's certain roles that I've
always wanted to play and there are
certain roles
that like I haven't been I haven't
stretched my I haven't stretched all the
muscles that I stretched in college
you know for yeah this audience yet that
I have their attention you know and I
and so I want them to see
the full spectrum and then
um you can judge my career or my
abilities on that
and then I'll take you 50 million I knew
you're gonna say it and I'll take you 50
million all right fair enough but let's
go back let's rewind about eight minutes
back to the lull we didn't finish that
thought because I went off in a tangent
because I lied while I wanted to ask you
some things but the lull the what do you
do what kind of things do you do for the
local because now you have kids you have
a wife you can't just also you get
really depressed and sad and you know
you got a family to take care of but
like we do unintentionally it's just
human nature but you know are your lows
low do you get anxiety what do you how
do you deal with it
I can't turn off the creative
um you know meter that's constantly
going in my head
so I'm constantly writing
when I have a lull and I'm not getting
any work
I will
direct I'll write something for myself
and I'll direct the movie I'll and I'll
I'll just
put out an independent film where I
could that I it's like a vehicle for me
like I'll just
I know I just have to but I feel like I
just have to keep the momentum going
um I am constantly
because I have kids and a wife it's a
huge motivating factor to be like okay I
cannot sit around I have to
I have to you know hustle I'm constantly
hustling I'm hustling even when things
are good like I'm constantly trying to
figure out what the next gig is
uh creating gigs for myself creating
like new new Pathways to to make money
yeah
um with these abilities like it's
Non-Stop and it helps when there's
nothing going on it keeps you focused
work begets work
um
gives you confidence you know you're
just like okay
like I can I can still do what I love
and
and keep the you know keep my passion
going and and keep myself and satisfied
you know
um and there's a lot of [__]
uh
like
I know
that there there was like those times
during those lulls when nothing's going
on
when people you're the closest people
that you have to you
who have supported you all the way up
until that point are suddenly like yeah
maybe it's time to you know throw in the
Hat
you know and and when you're just like
what
are you kidding like we've got this far
now you think like it's over like
to use that and prove them wrong
um huge motivating things you know it's
just like
um
and then
there is there's like a luck Factor
there's like a wishing on I I wished on
a star like whenever whenever there were
LOLs
um
before I I have a transition before uh
New Year's
especially during these times
um I would make a wish
for some kind of guidance some kind of
you know miracle to happen and
um
and it happened it was answered every
single time
and we can we can go into that whole
thing manifesting things and
intention
manifesting you know things that you
want in your life
um I
I believe it's real that you can you can
do these things yeah because I'm I'm
living it like the secret or The
Celestine Prophecy or like wanting
something so bad and and having this
vision of it and really believing it and
imagining yourself being there and that
you belong and that I believe a lot of
that too I really do I think again it
comes down to you've got to really
believe it you can't just be like I'm
gonna be a star huh I'm gonna I'm gonna
do I'm gonna make millions of dollars
you gotta really really believe it and
also be motivated to do whatever it
takes yeah you gotta you have to feel it
in your heart to the point where
you're you believe it's already
happening
and guess who's really good at that
actors yeah yeah actors are really good
at believing stuff
making making themselves believe
situations make so the art of
manifesting stuff is
the universe
doesn't understand want and need
it understands the vibration of the
emotion so if you're like
if you're vibrating at that frequency of
yeah I am so happy that this stuff is
already happening
then the universe says yes let's
continue with that feeling yeah that's
it you have to just vibrate at the same
frequency as what you want if you
vibrate with worry
and need then you'll get that
interesting
drinking your Mimosa this is uh very
insightful as your list as I forget I'm
even interviewing you I kind of start
like yeah it's like it's just this is a
conversation this is like a interesting
I like that you weren't expecting that I
wasn't expecting to not actually be
interviewing but being really in it
in it to win it
um you know I gotta ask you this because
she was a good friend of mine Carrie
Fisher and you know you got to work with
her and fanboys
love her she was she was she's getting
mad at me because I said God you let my
grandma and she's like [__] you and I go
no no no no no I mean like your house is
always open you're like hey stop by in
between auditions have a sandwich in the
fridge go and do whatever I don't have
to be home I stayed at her house for
four months and went up for bungalows
because I was going through a rough time
and uh it was it was just insane she's
so giving so wonderful and it was a real
loss it was a real loss but what was
your experience I don't know how long
you got to work with her but what was it
like for you she was on set
for a day she was the nurse in that
scene
um and I just you know it was a it was a
sad scene where she because our friends
um
uh Chris Marquette Linus
he's dying and he's not feeling well and
she's like supposed to come out and just
be like he's he can see you now you know
right right I'm supposed to be sad
and I couldn't get the [__] smile off
my face
she is a trip dude
she
um
this is how I always always remember her
we're all we all came back from a break
and we're sitting around in the waiting
room where she's supposed to come in and
tell us to come and meet with the Linus
and we're like we're waiting on Carrie
and we're like okay yeah where's Carrie
and she just saw I'm here
if we looked down and she's just like
took her break on the floor
just like lying on the floor
eating eating fruit loops off of her
chest
and she's like hey guys
you know she was Jesus so relaxed and
just like you know she's been living on
sets her whole life and
uh there was just like this I don't know
I just we just had so much reverence for
her and then of course I was so jealous
that Marquette got to kiss her you know
I was just like [__]
oh that's amazing you know uh she did an
episode of Smallville and oh yeah uh
they were looking for her too they were
looking for Carrie and they found her in
the you know those giant air
conditioning vents that they put on set
the little like worm-like things that
are really big that blow cold air into
the she was she was in one cooling off
yeah she was living in there
yeah she left she likes to get into a
little Nook oh Mr rest in peace Yeah man
so
honored that I got to meet her got to
meet Billy D on on uh Fanboys yeah
um got to meet some a lot of my favorite
people like I love Star Wars
a whole episode we could talk about Star
Wars
you know it's funny care I've talked
about this but she gave me her Force
awakens chair
oh Carrie Fisher uh yeah it was how did
she become such good friends with her
what was that my an assistant at the
time and she called her assistant called
my assistant and said hey this is Carrie
Fisher's assistant and Carrie's daughter
is a big fan of Smallville and Carrie
wants to know if you could send her an
autograph and I go uh could she send me
a Return of the Jedi autograph when
she's almost naked with Jabba the Hutt
and so I still have the picture it says
Blow Me Carrie and we became friends and
she'd invite me to her parties we
actually threw a party together
and uh I just started hanging out with
her and going I I again I've always had
this feeling my my listeners know that I
never really felt like I belong when I'm
around big celebrities and things but I
go to this these gatherings and it'd be
Carrie Fisher uh Harrison Ford uh you
know uh Robert Downey Jr
um uh oh Nicole Kidman and like you know
15 people hanging at her house all the
time like Meryl Streep and like Michael
get in here say hello I'm like
hey Meryl Streep hey George Lucas hey
she didn't give a [__] she was like this
is my friend this is Michael I don't
care how big stars you are he's welcome
and she always made you feel like that
and we just hit it off she knew I came
from a dysfunctional family and
obviously she did too and uh you know
Debbie Reynolds lived in in front of her
in the little her little house that in
on the same property right so we did
down and visit Debbie who's watching QVC
till three in the morning and she'd have
all these pictures of like all these big
stars saying to Debbie I love you and
it's Frank Sinatra and just crazy [__]
man so that's how we became friends
um those Postcards From The Edge
Postcards From The Edge man that movie
still makes me cry when Gene Hackman
says you have everything people love you
and she goes but I don't feel it
and I go oh man
that sucks but yeah I could understand
that uh uh well we're almost done here
uh you're a big horror fan
yeah dakara yeah I love horror
I thought you were horror fan I don't
know you published a graphic novel
horror Anthology Moon Lake a collection
of stories Chronicles the past present
future of the most haunted town on Earth
Moon Lake I gotta check this out
yeah I'll send you some uh I'll send it
to you if you want yeah yeah we're
making an animated show out of that
um that is my homage to Twilight Zone
and Tales from the Crypt and Heavy Metal
the movie
um yeah I like uh like uh I dig horror
like I like my my horror is
um
like love Jaws yeah love Shining
um Love Like Cujo I would just watched
future last week again I have a horror
movie group and we watch Cujo and it
still holds up oh and I loved it so much
I emailed D Wallace
from the mother from you know in Cujo
and E.T and done tons of [__] and I go I
want to be in the pocket she goes sure
so she's coming over the house I'm
stoked I'm like a nerd like that oh man
yeah that movie scared the [__] out of
me because I had we had straight
straight dogs in my neighborhood and I
was like any one of those dogs could be
a Cujo we named our dog Cujo it was a
poodle when we were kids little little
dog
uh yeah man like those are those are my
jam like
the recent ones
not many good ones not many good ones
yeah I'm uh I'm like they're scary as
hell like this like like there's some
paranormal ones like this circle there's
they're kind of they but they freak me
out and in a way that it I don't know
it's different it's it is different it's
raw yeah you know what messed me up as a
kid you remember the howling oh yeah
remember the uh
the werewolf transformation
terrifying I think it was better or
almost better than the American Werewolf
in London transformation that one too is
messed up both messed up because that
was the pain of it yeah so freaky man
there's some movies that just stick with
you there's moments in time like
um yeah all right look this is called
[__] talking with [__] talking with Dan
fogler okay
fogler I said it right
yeah good job
uh these are
these are from my patrons uh they get to
ask questions join patreonpatre.com uh
inside of you they they really help the
show more than they know here we go Tom
and does Dan still crank up Def Leppard
when their songs come on
yeah I can't play ping pong without
listening to Def Leppard
dude I love Def Leppard
did so many fun actors and and Balls of
Fury
oh oh my God so many fun actors holy
[__] including Christopher Walken who is
like my one of my favorites let's do
dual walkings so Dan how long have you
have you been an actor well
let me tell you something
I've been an actor
since
I was born I came out of my mother's
vagina and I was holding the umbilical
and I was using it as a microphone
strumming it like a base and everyone
was clapping
I had 50 million dollars
damn
quit acting I'll give you 50 million
would you do
I still have so many more roles that I
want to do
including
the Chris Walken story
have you ever been called Dan Fogelberg
incessantly
Fogelberg
Folgers
apologies crystals
happen fogler
I don't know what's so hard about fogler
you do it's great
um Maddie yes I gotta stop it any fun
memories from take me home tonight that
you'd still like that you'd like to
share yes yeah
um I love that movie I had so much fun
in that movie that movie was just a
constant party I loved
um
they used every single Scarface
impression
they use it's all sprinkled out
throughout the whole movie amazing um
yeah and um
that scene in the bathroom with Angie
Everhart uh was
with the the future man and the leather
outfit do you know who that is that that
is a is his last name is Frankenstein
that guy was related to doctor
no yeah it was part of his lineage
really
yeah oh my God
that was the most surreal moment of my
life
with her smacking me bruises up without
my ribs she's riding me and smacking me
and he's off on Frankenstein in his
leather outfit
did you tell her to really hit you or
you're like no I did not tell her to
really hit me but you know what are you
gonna argue with her
uh she really beat the [__] out of me
but uh the reactions were wonderful
Danny spinning gold looks like a great
film for those of us that love the music
of the 70s what is Dan's favorite song
on the soundtrack oh yeah
I love all the George Clinton stuff
uh Parliament Funkadelic we go there we
we do we we do a little kiss you know he
discovers kiss
Casablanca records
um so and yeah I mean like if you're a
music lover
there's all that disco Diana Ross
um
Bill Withers man holy [__] what's your
favorite band from these 70s and 80s
my favorite band from the 70s and 80s
you could name two 70s and one in the
80s oh two different ones yeah sure um
okay well
um I really got into the Zeppelin I got
into the doors that's a little before I
uh uh
um Aerosmith and The Black Crows wow I
just saw the black crows
um
recently in London here
and they were amazing God damn it they
sound wonderful they're singing the
whole Shake Your Money Maker album and
that was oh my God what am I in high
school right now it was crazy I've never
been a black crows fan maybe I need to
listen to them more but I play hockey
with their manager of many years and I
he always talks about him I'm like oh
yeah I'd rather listen to the Counting
Crows what's what's your jam and I mean
do you do you like that because they're
like a classic rock I love 70s 80s 90s I
can go on and on but I like the doors I
like Zeppelin I like the eagles I like
uh I like Yacht Rock I love a little
Christopher Cross when I'm driving I
like a little Def Leppard I like uh
again the Creedence a lot lately yeah I
like alternative I like the Cure I like
Psychedelic Furs OMD uh Morrissey Smiths
all that stuff I listen to a bit of
everything but 70s 80s and a little 90s
uh last question little Lisa if you go
back in time yeah [__] girl
her time
then go back on set to uh time on a set
to change one thing what would it be
one thing
Marty go back in time
is that boy
it could be any said okay
uh well the I wish I could go back in
time
to win Michael J fox
forced me to do an impression of him for
him
I I wish
that I didn't do the impression for him
that I just went straight into my Doc
Brown because that would have been a
much better
re uh less awkward situation is your is
your Michael J fox Marty good
so here's the situation so I'm doing the
spelling bee show you want to hear this
story tell me
so it's this is why it's good to know a
couple different Impressions so
I'm doing a spelling bee show
and I'm like I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna leave and my buddy is just like
hey uh I mean after the show the show
was great but I was like I just want to
go home and my buddy was like Michael J
fox is in the green room he wants to
meet you I was like [__] so I'm like
running around I felt like I just missed
him and I was like oh man and I turned a
corner and I'm just face to face with my
Michael J fox and he just saw he's just
like hey man and he's like I'm like hey
he's like I I hear you do an impression
of me and I'm just like oh [__] and uh I
was like yeah I'd do it but it's it's
from my comedy act and I'm just like
it's not I I'm not I don't want to do it
it's like do it like David Spade you
know he does one and and I was just like
I was like oh
he's like yeah Dana Carvey does
it's like okay I'll do it and and I go I
go this is what I do for my ACT I go I
go whoa doc you tell me you built a time
machine I had a Mallory and then he
looks at me
I mean family looks at me and he goes he
goes
you know my voice isn't that high
hey
it's playing with his family and I'm
just like
and then and then like I was like how do
I fix this how do I fix this so
instantly I turn around and I go
out I don't have my hands I do like my
best stock Brown and he turns around
he's like wow and then these family
started laughing and then
and then it was okay oh my God I wish
that I could have gone back and just be
like no no I'm not gonna do it Marty and
then we could have had that a similar I
don't know if he would have made me do
it just never no matter what never do
the impression for the person even if
they ask you to do it that's my advice
what other Impressions can you do
besides Pacino what's your best Pacino
line
ah no that's the stuff oh oh my best
Pacino line
is
I mean I I guess it's you know she got a
nice ass and you got your head
stuck what happened
that's pretty good it's great it's okay
I do the screaming Pacino that's correct
um I gotta like I love doing the walking
yeah uh I got a cub I do Nicholson I
like doing Nicholson that's good are you
out of your goddamn mind like a look
yeah I do a little Nicholson too I love
my favorite line I've talked about it is
in The Shining when Shelley Duvall goes
Jack Jack someone's in the hotel they
heard Danny and he goes
are you out of your [__] mind you out
of your [__] mind it's so brilliant
it's good yeah yeah yeah
Mr Grady what's that one line
he says that I forgot what he does
[Music]
what does he say she says something she
goes
I forgot what it was I forgot what it
was but I love Nicholson oh man great
little haired dog that bit me yeah
there's different there's different you
know Nicholson's is like early early
Nicholson and then as he gets older it
gets deeper and deeper yeah
Joker Nicholson what does he say when he
takes the things out of the shiny takes
the this fuses out of the car and he
goes oh Wendy you got a real pig
something coming to you what does he say
oh I don't you got a real big surprise I
forgot you ever seen you ever seen the
behind the scenes on that brilliant it's
a 30 minute one that uh Francis Ford
Coppola's uh daughter made right and
it's like a 30 minute and he's brush you
see I don't know if people are gonna
find this fairy yeah that's it yeah yeah
make sure your teeth are fresh
breath for my for the people that I work
with love that but he's he's meeting
that girl and she's like obviously like
he's meeting that woman and she's
obviously they've obviously had
something in the past yeah and she's
like you you don't remember me at all
he's like I meet a lot of people every
day you know me hands I shake
you look like him when you say it like
they obviously had sex at some point you
know oh my God I have no clue
you look like him your face be you
become him it's weird
yeah this has been a real blast man
you're you're fantastic I I'm I'm so
happy for all the great work you've done
and the the uh the accolades and people
really paying attention to you because
they should
um people should watch the offer it's
it's got to be one of your favorite
things you've done right
oh God yeah that was amazing like what a
dream come true you're a genius this is
this is a gift I'm glad we got to
finally connect it was very easy to talk
to you you have great stories and let's
keep in touch and I want you you're
gonna send me something right you're
gonna send me a book I'll send you all
my books I'll send you links to them and
um yeah and don't be a stranger at these
cons man we should hang out I would love
that dude I would love that
cool all right um yeah I'll send you
I'll send you all the fogler's fictions
Man by the way uh if you ever do a
podcast
I got yeah I do podcasts what's your
I do a 40 Dan fogler 40 Experience
Podcast and you should come on my
podcasts we'll we'll have a blast you
tell me when I'll be there
all right
um next couple weeks man I was thinking
a cool podcast naming for you you
already have it would be the fogler
files
yeah yeah I still have a section of the
the podcast where I do Tales From Beyond
the Veil where we talk about all sorts
of paranormal conspiracy stuff and the
fogler files would be a good name just
to like just do that stuff a section
it's now time for the folklift files
yeah all right dude you're awesome
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you and I will talk to you very soon
you feel me did you feel me inside of
you I felt you deeply my friend deeply
organically
later buddy
thanks man thanks for having me
I like this guy he was just really fun
um again we didn't know each other it's
always like you never know what you're
you know okay are they gonna get my vibe
and he just got he just enjoyed things
we bounced off each other
and I'm glad to see him like doing drama
and getting noticed for this because uh
you know I think sometimes you see
you know I think when I was doing
comedies I was just doing you know like
I did this comedy and this pilot in this
sitcom and this and this is fun and I
was kind of known as you know maybe a
funny guy and he'll just do comedies and
I thought that's what I would do
and then somebody you know they gave me
the chance and um
Smallville
to play Lex Luthor and the next thing
you know I'm playing this it's just
crazy you I think you know I think he
said it or actually might have been um
JK Simmons when I interviewed him
he said that a lot of time comedians or
maybe Jim Gaffigan Gaffigan said
comedians it's easier for them to do
drama and it makes sense I think a lot
of times there's like all this
insecurity with actors and all this
dysfunction and improving themselves and
you know they're a little dramatic and
dark and and uh maybe that's why I don't
know but anyway thank you Dan fogler and
uh if you're just listening to the end
of this there's a whole bunch of fun
stuff like joining patreon and
supporting the podcast and uh my new
album uh sunspin never is what it is is
out there go to sunspin.com and uh we
are also streaming everywhere and be
sure to go to Creation Con in Dallas to
see me and Tom willing to Smallville
nights and all that right now top tier
patrons these are the folks that uh you
know they do it they keep me together
here we go Ryan
[Music]
ha
Joshua deal
Jennifer and
Stacy El Jamal eternity
Kimberly Mikey
down to tremo 99 moles Santiago M Chad
Lee and P Janina
Maya P Maddie esper Linda
Chris H Dave h
G ready
[Music]
I am a dead City
Beach
[Music]
Corey
Heather L Jacob
beat the hell to Megan T you're so swell
Mel s
you're the best Orlando C it's just you
and me Caroline R what are you doing
Christine s Eric H Shane and you
friend Emma R and you m said Luigi 77 my
friend or a call
and I'm into Orange
Stephanie
K2
jorel billies Jim and Jay the NJ
r
[Music]
thank you so much patrons
that were the top tier patrons in a song
should we just start doing that every
time it's just a new song oh my God that
was so good that deserved to be like
Grammy nominated
what ass capped I don't know what it
means but ass cap you know yeah the the
recording something needed to be ass
capped
yeah
yeah uh
Michael Rosenberg from the Hollywood
Hills in California Southern California
I'm Ryan taze I'm upstairs here he's
very calm today he's rested I am not
rested I'm not either Vega's still
hitting my ass little wave to the camera
uh we love you guys thank you for uh
choosing this podcast pasta cast thanks
for
making this podcast your podcast today
um I hope you enjoyed it and keep tuning
in even if you don't know the you know
people sometimes were like I don't even
know this guest but I tune in to hear
what they have to say and I learned
something and that's cool you know what
I mean yeah that's cool so thank you
thanks and uh always
be good to yourself that's most
important be good to yourself we'll see
you next week
[Music]